diese Pizza seine eigene fokaca und
viele andere köstigkeiten gibt es in
Holles Lieblingsrestaurant viel Spaß mit
diesem Video wir sind schon mittend drin
ich sag Euch so viel es wird geil wir
haben einiges zu essen und ich freue
mich sehr darauf also ich muss sagen ich
war ein bisschen überrascht als du
italienisches Restaurant geschickt hast
es geht natürlich auch ein bisschen
darum dass du mir sowas zeigst wo gehst
du privat hin so ne dein
Lieblingsrestaurant wenn du Gäste hast
beispielsweise ich bin privat hier sag
wo gehen wir was geiles essen aber
irgendwie ich finde bei Holle denkt man
nicht an italienisches Essen absolut
nicht aber für mich ging es auch darum
ich bin also wer mich kennt weiß ja ich
bin auf Burger dönerebene vielleicht
auch mal Pizza das ist so das wo ich
viel unterwegs bin einach so dieses
geile comfort food so wo man sich wohl
fühlt wenn man es ist ja richtig und ich
das Problem ist auch würde ich dir jetzt
ein Burger Laden zeigen das meistens so
es gibt einmal den heftigen Burger so
der ist es und dann gehen wir dahin ich
zeig dir ein Burger und ich wollde so
ein bisschen abwechslungsreicher und
wenn ich den mal privat essen gehe dann
gehe ich ja gerade nicht Burgeressen
Döner essen sondern dann auch mal
irgendwas was ein bisschen was anderes
ist und deshalb hier die fukaca die will
ich dir unbedingt zeigen weil ich meine
gesehen zu haben dass du auch mal ein
Video gemacht hast da waren wir selber
beim Italiener mal du meinst die haben
so geile Sandwich dachte ich okay das
könnte dir bestimmt auch sehr gefallen
wenn auf die Karte gucken wir haben
Panne also Brot crostoni das ist so
belegtes Brot wie ich wie ich lese Salat
vokaca so Aufschnitt frittierte Pizza
sexy mag ich sehr sehr gerne kriegt man
nicht überall also das ist so ein Ding
das das gibt's nicht an jeder Ecke Pizza
und außerdem auch noch Yoki es gibt
schon viel was ist so das was du hier
immer bestellst also ich würde sagen wir
nehmen eine Dreier Kombi und das sind
auch die die ich so bestelle
stolzerweise darf ich behaupten die
fukac hatten sie gar nicht in der Karte
die haben sie jetzt reingenommen weil so
viele danach gefragt haben nach meinem
Video du da warst ja genau genau istr
ohne Witz ich liebe ausgefallene P Leute
wir bestellen einfach mal dann gucken
wir was uns erwartet wundert euch
übrigens nicht dass nicht so viel los
ist wir sind gerade zur Mittagszeit hier
da ist normalerweise nicht so viel los
abends ist hier brechend voll wir warten
jetzt aufs Essen und vielleicht können
wir schon ein bisschen was bei der
Zubereitung sehen gut warm
knuspis Belag ist ganz einfach unsere
strata Käse das ist K von Bata Käse dann
haben wir bruskette Tomaten einfach
große romatomaten gewürfelt mit knubi
ein bisschen Origano Basilikum
SalzPfeffer und auch hier drauf ganz
wichtig die beste Zutaten und gute
Quantität ja das heißt muss man die
Zutaten auch merken ja nicht nur kananz
auch wichtig viel pistaen drauf lass so
auf die tell klein Basilikum vom h
ja so meine da gibt's auch so deine
fokcia hier haben wir unsere so
pizzakissen welche nennen wir spak
Napoli napolotanische streetfood gemacht
mit Tomaten Basilikum und Parmesan und
dazu haben wir unsere Sauerteigbrot
gerostet und dann belegt mit fasona
rinata und wintertfel ja dazu zwei
ararancini Mozzarella Bällchen und dann
H sieht super gut ausa wir haben gerade
schon gesagt warum steht in der Karte
eigentlich nicht poa hol nächste Menu
machen wir wirklich machen wir ser ger
endlich ist es soweit hol oder geil ja
ich habe eben schon zu dir gesagt offcam
was würdest du sagen du bestellst du
bist das erste mal weißt von nichts
kriegst das hier Flash also ich finde
das sehr sehr sexy also ich habe schon
viel gut italienisch gegessen muss ich
sagen an der Stelle ne aber das was wir
hier sehen das sieht schon echt gut aus
wie fangen wir an ich mach dir alles
nach du bist heute mein Papa und ich ich
guck mal wie du mach okay Papa holärt ja
ich würde sagen B Schnecken hier jetzt
einmal rein also das wä meine
Vorgehensweise ich würde mir jetzt
einfach so ein Bächen greifen Arancini
oder Mozzarella Bächen oh mit Arancini
komm neh Arancini arancino arancina ich
glaube das ist je nachdem ob man aus
Sardinien oder Sizilien kommt heißt es
anders aber einfach Risotto gefüllt geil
da kommt auf so eine geile Idee
überhaupt es ist wirklich perfekt ich
glaub irgendjemand der risotte übrig
hatte probieren wir ja geil schön käsig
ja kein Ragu drin ich hatte Ragu
erwartet aber fehlt gar nicht K Cavallo
RAG ne es gibt in ganz vielen
auspringung sehr mächtig und der Käse
ist wichtig der Käse fehlen wir
Katastrophe aber da gibt so eine leichte
Unternote irgendwo auf basic ne also
plump und geil Käse ummantelt frittiert
das gibt's hier das kriegst du teilweise
auch bei Fastfood restus aber schmeckt
überall das ist jetzt nicht so die
trinchärfe hier zeigt sich nicht ob wir
heute in im besten Restaurant ever sind
sondern hier zeig ich mal hier zeigt
also wenn du davon nicht gefleisch bist
weiß ich auch nicht das ist deine Nummer
ein das ist Nummer ein würde ich
jemanden eine Sache empfehlen wenn nur
eine in Hamburg dann wür ich sagen ist
das oder ich wür ein Burger vielleicht
noch empfehlen ja das wäre bei
hopsburger der Italien Burger okay lass
uns fok anschneiden im Prinzip sind wir
hier wegen dieser fokata Polle liebt das
über alles boah knuspert schon so
richtig schönim schneiden F und ich weiß
nicht ob das gerade untergegangen ist ob
das ein Video drin war diese fokataa so
wie sie hier ist ist nur wegen Holle auf
der Karte und der Chef meinte jeder
bestellt sie wird jetzt auch unbenannt
in Foka Holle ja m du musst mal echt
genau drauf achten ich weiß gar nicht
mehr was war ob jetzt STZ tell ist weil
es auch lange her dass ich ihn
das gegessen es ist einfach so ein
geiler Kontrast mit dieser alleine das
Ding hier in der Hand zu halten ne es
ist saftig du hast unten dieses total
fluffige so ein bisschen aufgeweichte
Brot oben drauf den perfekten Crunch
also das merke ich schon vom in der Hand
halten motadella ist sowieso eine Wucht
ne eine Waffe dann noch stratatella
Aufstrich Tomate also wenn ich das sehe
es kann nur geil sein es halt halt auch
diesen Sandwich Charakter schell du
bestellst irgendwo ein Sandwich was ja
auch V vom Profil hier so vom Aufschnitt
irgendwie ähnlich aussieht rein da jetzt
bin ich so gespannt ich finde das hat
einfach alles das hat frischen durch ein
Basilikum das hat diese sahnigkeit durch
den statteller Deftigkeit durch die
durch die motadella und dieses Knusper
noch du benutzt gerne ist mir
aufgefallen das Wort himmlisch und ich
finde hier trifft es wie die Faust aufs
Auge weil es hat so so ganz das ist
nicht so in your face das ist nicht so
ich habe so vi so röstarom wie ein
Burger oder irgendwie sowas super
würziges so wie in so einer
Knoblauchsoße oder whatever sondern es
ist so sehr dezent so du hast die
statatella die so Milch cremig ist dazu
Mortadella und die gesamtkreation macht
nur Sinn und und macht einfach nur Spaß
also es schmeckt richtig richtig gut ich
bin auch immer Fan von Sachen wo du noch
klar rausschmeckst schmecken kannst was
es ist ich bin auch Fan von von von der
anderen Variante an dem Fall merkst du
einfach alles zwischendrin hast du diese
pistaie noch oben drauf du merkst diese
Tomatenwürfel die so ein bisschen an das
was oben auf dem wie hei noch mal diese
geröstete Brot mit dem
Dings sind auch so haben so leichten
Knoblauch dran und so also du merkst
alles klar raus selbst selbst selbst die
Creme die weiße strazatella Creme ich
kann nur sagen tu mich schwer es nicht
auf einmal wegzauen aber W natürlich
auch alles andere mit Appetit noch
testen es schmeckt verdammt gut ah eine
Frage wollte ich dir die ganze Zeit
stellen Holle du bist wahrscheinlich so
die Person die ich kenne die am meisten
rumreißt wie viel Kilometer ballerst du
im Jahr im Auto so 90 bis 100 000 oh
mein Gott bei dir ist so die Maxime wenn
du morgens hinfahren kannst und abends
zurück dann machst du es ne aber 90 bis
100.000 km im Jahr das ist absurd also
für jeden der ein bisschen Auto fährt
der weiß das ist verrückt und du bist
auch muss ich auch ein Kompliment für
auschen du bist immer überall am Start
direkt also da manchmal auch von mir
fasziniert und auch wenn ich eigentlich
so eigene lobeshimnen hasse aber
teilweise merke ich wo die Jungs sagen
wie hast du das gemacht wir haben
vorgestern geöffnet ich bin schon am
Start so will halt immer der erste auch
gerne sein so wenn es irgendwie möglich
ist bitte lass uns in diese Pizza frit
dabei wir haben so lange rumgelabert
dass S nicht mehr warm ist aber man
fühlt wirklich noch das ist wie es ist
ja geisteskrank die Textur also du
versinkst das ist krass das ist so das
ist die Textur ist so dass man es
einfach gerne
anfasst ja re in die P da fallen mir
auch andere Dinge
an kannst einfach machen wenn du willst
ne ich LEH mich zurück ja
so oh hast du straffe Oberschenkel
Bruder richtig geil also finde ich geil
das gibt's wie gesagt auch nicht an
jeder Ecke sind sind schon paar special
Sachen hier die es auf der Karte zu
finden gibt macht Spaß ist einfach wenn
du so mit Leuten hier sitzt was ist
hammergeil rein
damit hat mir auf die Lippen gebissen oh
mal KST du den Schmerz weg du holst auch
mit seinen Sprüchen immer so eine Seite
von mir raus die ich so sonst gar nicht
auf Youtube ze ich GL nicht aber du hast
sie in dir ich sie in mir ich bin viel
mehr als ihr seht man muss aber auch
sagen ihr sitzt ja alle immer nicht von
Max ich habe eine Frau ich habe Kinder
wenn du von Max sitzt du willst ih
einfach nur küssen es ist wirklich so da
kommt eine Magie von Max springt auf ein
krass Leute wenn das so ist lass noch
mal ein Like da abonniert den Kanal
schaut Holle vorbei ist natürlich ganz
oben verlinkt eine letzte Vorspeise
haben wir noch das ist wirklich ein
Feuerwerk also geile abwechslungsreiche
italienische Vorspeisen jetzt verlassen
Italien ein bisschen das Rind ist zwar
italienisch aber geröstetes
Sauerteigbrot mit Tatar Trüffel wo du
selbst sagst gucken wir mal wie weß
nicht mehr Brot auch Haus gemacht hier
kommen Leute kaufen nur Brot ja sieht
man ja auch direkt so bei uns an der
Seite aber das try Brot geiles Brot al
ist auch besser als letzt Mal muss ich
sagen letztte mal keine Ahnung oder ist
mir nicht so aufgefallen schön grobes
Salz geil mit Essig gearbeitet ja geil
ich glaube die Vorspeisen haben schon
mal auf ganzer Linie überzeugt sehr geil
freut mich ich nehme den Laden wenn ich
hier reinkomme den Ofen aber vor allem
als Pizzeria war und dann muss die Pizza
auch überzeugen deshalb würde ich sagen
schauen wir mal zu wie jetzt hier
gezaubert wird und essen wir eine
richtig geile napolitanische Pizza fre
mir so hier haben wir paar Zutaten
welche gehören dazu grundsätzlich unsere
Pizza valtelina habe ich gesagt wtelina
nimmt die Name vom bra Rinderschinken
wir haben so frischees
Spinat dann haben
wira dann haben wir zweien noch dazu
zigenkäsecreme und zum Schluss haben wir
unsere rotop Tomaten Nusse Parmesan ein
bisschen
knubi sieht ein bisschen auch bundter
aus mald Salz noch ein bisschen drauf
pizeline das ist
Pizza alter Schwede sieht diese Pizza
geil aus das ist wirklich eine Gourmet
Pizza schöne schöne tigerung rundum no
ein Gericht hier unsere mit Kürbiscreme
und skamp einfach noch was dazu die
Variante so heftig die Kreation und rein
von der Kreation würde ich sagen ist das
geilste aber wenn ich sagen msste
gesamtpizza die beste die ich gegessen
habe das nicht nein davon überzeugen wir
uns jetzt mal bin sehr gespannt was du
das wir haben wirklich auch eine schöne
tigerung von unten und ich könnte den
Finger wegnehmen die würde sich sowas
von schnell verneigen dafür kann ich
einstehen also probieren wir mal die
Pizza
Balten das einfach auch von Gegenspiel
du hast diese Röstung die so bitter
dunkel ist und den dieser feine
frischkel der das ganze abdämpft absolut
geiler Gegenspieler das das ist ja keine
Tomate drauf ich habe eine ne also klar
da sind kleine Tomaten aber das ist
keine Tomatensoße sondern dieses
spinatpüe aber so Pizza werde so eine
grüne Pizza habe ich noch nie gegessen
ich habe gerade gedacht was ist denn
jetzt hier gerade so anders aber es ist
auch eine sehr geileenweise anders weil
dieser Spinat schmeckt super frisch da
hast du einfach diese Vollmundigkeit von
dem Ziegenkäse also das ist richtig geil
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen langsam bin
ich richtig gut
satt aber das sollten wir unbedingt
probieren keine Pasta auf der Karte nur
ein ycki wir haben keine Pasta ne Nuri
nocki glöschen auch einfach geil
ne Kürbiscreme richtig scharf muss die
angebrat haben ja sieht man hier Schärfe
die scharf Schärfe man merkt diese
Rüstung die gehen durch die ganzen knck
durch die sind one point diecki und ich
finde mit dem Geschmack habe ich niemals
re das wird so eine sahnige
Angelegenheit schö geschmeidig mil aber
vololl Feuer drin feuerrüstung Parmesan
schön käsig Crem al zuca würde ich
nennen oder aber wirklich sehr sehr
lecker ich weiß gar nicht wenn ich die
Gerichte Ranken würde die wir heute alle
gegessen haben würde ich das auf jeden
Fall mit oben ansiedeln ist eine sehr
sehr geile Überraschung zum Schluss ein
Dessert geht noch und ich bin jetzt
schon mega happy dass wir hier waren
richtig geil danke dass du es mir
gezeigt hast dafür sehr danke dass ich
hier sein darf bestellen wir ein Dessert
und dann war das aber auch frische
espress drauf WoW und das ist unsere
cremoso salzig karamelleis Mascarpone
Sahne Schaum und Espresso drauf und hier
neben andere Version mit pistaeneis
mascarone und Salz dankeön dank danke
danke ich bin fast schon erleichtert
weil in der Folge mit Bern habe ich so
absurd viel essen müssen jetzt habe ich
das Gefühl ich habe geil gegessen ich
hatte einen guten Tag bei wert war ich
ich konnte nicht mehr der Mann hat mich
fertig gemacht deshalb richtig geil ich
freue mich jetzt noch auf das Dessert
gehen wir rein salzaramelleis das kann
ja nur lecker sein boah das ist wirklich
krank das ist es ist wirklich geil ich
habe auch viele italienisch gegessen so
das hatte ich noch nie we ob
hauskreation ist ich weiß auch nicht
aber ich das häufig aber ganz ehrlich da
le ich so weit aus dem Fenster eins der
besten Desserts die ich bisher hatte bit
danke schön ST alles gut alles gut danke
schön auch an Martin auf jeden Fall
kommt unbedingt hier vorbei spezagan in
Hamburg schreib mal in die Kommentare
wer mir noch sein Lieblingsrestaurant
zeigen soll und guckt unbedingt bei
Holle vorbei ganz oben verlinkt ciao
ciao danke schön